customer excellence deals with inquiries  covering the following areas  planning council tax housing and council  tax benefit  refusing recycling switchboard payments  and business rates and inquiries  relating to other council services  we are always happy to help so please  feel free to contact us on 01 626 361  101 or visit our main reception at ford  house newton abbott  www.teambridge.gov dot uk is the online  front face of teambridge not only can  you find information about every service  we supply you can report problems such  as a missed bin or save yourself time by  paying your council tax online  it is a 24 7 service containing  essential information for parents young  people businesses older people visitors  community and voluntary services